hé comment vous faites les gars, vous et vos
partenaires avez interdit une somme d'
argent substantielle à mon bienfaiteur et à la lumière des
événements récents, il craint d'
être remboursé, il veut s'asseoir
demain n'oubliez pas d'amener vos
copains en fait dit qu'il ne le fera pas  parlez à
tout le monde mais le noir oui je suis tellement désolé
je suis en retard vous me devez 400000
je vous offre messieurs une issue oh
tout ce que vous avez à faire est de récupérer le
voleur le retenir pendant 24 heures nous ne sommes pas des
criminels  si vous faites cela pour moi, je
considérerai l'ardoise propre
vous allez le chef des syndicats du crime noir le
neveu a été kidnappé est-ce que vous vous
moquez de moi cela fait une leçon à
apprendre ici aujourd'hui
quelqu'un reçoit la facture je passe
une bonne journée
quels sont  tu vas bien oh super
salut tu nous as baisé
risque professionnel tu sais qui était ce
gars ça veut dire que vous regardez à peu
près
où est le marquis Fleming oh tu sais
quelque chose oh mec je suis désolé mon mal je ne
me sens pas bien il y a eu un changement de
planifier un tu vas  fais exactement ce que je
veux que tu fasses d'accord, c'est que mon arme oh
c'est juste la cerise sur le gâteau